this report just came out yesterday i'm
not joking i did not find this in the
deep recesses of the internet this is
being
published by the mainstream even
left-wing outlets
doctors and researchers at the pentagon
are working to prevent a future pandemic
by developing a microchip that can go
under our skin that can detect a virus
this according to dr matt hepburn a
retired army infectious disease
physician
this is part of the defense advanced
research projects agency or darpa
which is a secret research agency not
that secret because we're talking about
it on the show
tasked with protecting soldiers from
contagious diseases and biological
weapons
i can't believe i'm saying this for the
second time
in what a week or two but it it seems
like alex jones and associated people
were sort of right i'm not saying
i want to be very clear i am not saying
that the government is currently
injecting people with microchips but
the news report is very clear they are
developing a microchip that can go under
a person's skin to detect diseases
the neck the headline that i'm going to
read tomorrow is going to be
breaking news pentagon confirms
that they are in fact turning the
frickin frogs gay that i wouldn't be
surprised
and by the way the epa and yale
university were
engaging in research on whether or not
chemicals in the water in connecticut
were turning the frickin frogs trans not
gay actually
returning them trans this is on the one
hand
i want to i want to back away for a
moment from all the theories about the
microchips and stuff like that on the
one hand this is incredibly
technologically impressive
okay i'm gonna put the political
question aside for a second i'm just
focusing on
the science or the technology or
whatever
it is very impressive that scientists
could develop a microchip
that can detect if you are coming down
with a virus and
you know beep or boop or something or
light up and tell you that you've got to
go
get some medical care that that is
that's genuinely very impressive
i don't want it don't want it not
interested
i don't care i am not
an adherent of the cult of public health
i know a lot of people are
at the cultural and the political level
that's how these sociopath politicians
and public health officials
have shut down our country for a year i
don't want it
if the option is
live 10 years longer with a microchip
under
under your skin that makes you neurotic
about
every time you're about to get a virus
or something and social distance and
wear the stupid masks and what all that
nonsense
but you live 10 years longer or don't
live 10 years longer
but don't live your life in the neurotic
paranoid fear of coming down with the
sniffles and ultimately
the neurotic fear of death i'm going to
take the latter
because no one here gets that alive i'd
like to live a good
good long life emphasis on the good i
suppose but i know look eventually
if i am to have a future it ain't going
to be here because we're all
we're all going down eventually and and
hopefully that that natural fact helps
you to think about supernatural and
eternal things
or we can all just become neurotic
ninnies and put microchips in our skin
and worry about getting
the flu or whatever if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
you